et j'étais certain que mes profs ne le seraient pas non plus.
Après tout, ils ne les ont jamais utilisées pour enseigner.
Les BD ou romans illustrés n'étaient pas autorisé durant les heures de lecture,
et n'étaient pas vendus à notre foire annuelle du livre.
Cependant, j'ai continué à lire des BD, et j'ai même commencé à en créer.
Finalement, je suis devenu un dessinateur publié
qui écrit et dessine des BD pour vivre.
Je suis aussi devenu un professeur de lycée.
J'ai enseigné dans ce lycée : Lycée Bishop O'Dowd, à Oakland - Californie.
J'ai enseigné un peu de maths, d'art, mais principalement l'informatique.
et ce durant 17 ans.
Encore tout jeune enseignant,
j'ai essayé d'introduire des BD dans ma classe.
Je me souviens avoir annoncé à mes étudiants le premier jour,
que j'étais aussi dessinateur de BD.
Mon intention n'était pas de leur apprendre l'art de la BD,
mais j'espérais leur faire penser que j'étais « cool ».
(Rires)
J'avais tort.
Nous étions dans les années 1990,
et les BD n'avaient pas le prestige dont elles bénéficient aujourd'hui.
Mes étudiants n'ont pas pensé que j'étais « cool », mais plutôt « nul ».
Pire, quand les cours ont commencé à être difficiles,
ils ont utilisé les BD pour me distraire.
Ils levaient la main et posaient des questions comme :
« M. Yang, selon vous, qui va gagner le combat : Superman ou Hulk ? »
(Rires)
J'ai vite compris que je devais garder mon enseignement et mes dessins séparés.
Apparemment, mon intuition à l'école primaire était correcte.
La BD n'avait pas sa place à l'école.
Mais là encore, j'avais tort.
Quelques années plus tard,
j'ai appris par expérience directe le pouvoir pédagogique potentiel des BD.
Un semestre, on m'a demandé de reprendre un cours d'algèbre.
Ce serait pour un long terme et j'ai accepté. Mais il y avait un os.
À l'époque, j'étais aussi le technologue en éducation de l'école,
ce qui signifiait que toutes les deux semaines,
je devais manquer deux ou trois périodes de ce cours d'algèbre
pour apporter mon soutien à un autre professeur
dans une activité liée à l'informatique.
Pour mes étudiants en algèbre, c'était une catastrophe.
Avoir un long remplaçant est déjà une mauvaise nouvelle,
mais un remplaçant du remplaçant? Çà ne pouvait pas être pire.
Cherchant à fournir une certaine cohérence à mes étudiants,
j'ai commencé à me filmer donnant un cours.
Je me proposais de remettre ces vidéos à mon remplaçant.
J'ai essayé de rendre ces vidéos les plus intéressantes possible.
J'ai même ajouté des petits effets spéciaux.
Par exemple, après avoir terminé un problème au tableau,
je tapais dans mes mains et le tableau s'effaçait comme par magie.
(Rires)
Je trouvais ça super.
J'étais persuadé que mes étudiants allaient adorer ça.
Mais j'avais tort.
(Rires)
Ces présentations vidéo ont été un désastre.
Certains de mes étudiants sont venus me dire :
« M. Yang, on vous trouvait ennuyeux en chair et en os,
mais en vidéo, vous êtes insoutenable. »
(Rires)
Donc, j'ai fait une deuxième tentative désespérée mais sous forme de BD.
Je les ai faites très rapidement, sans planification.
J'ai pris un crayon et dessiné une planche après l'autre,
en imaginant ce que je voulais dire au fur et à mesure.
Ces BD de présentation avaient quatre à six pages.
Je les ai photocopiées et remises à mon remplaçant pour mes étudiants.
À ma grande surprise, ces BD ont été un succès.
Mes étudiants me demandaient d'en faire
même quand j'étais là pour le cours.
Il semble qu'ils me préféraient en BD plutôt qu'en personne.
(Rires)
Cela m'a étonné car mes étudiants faisaient partie d'une génération
élevée avec les écrans.
Donc, je pensais qu'ils préféreraient apprendre à partir d'un écran
plutôt que d'un format papier.
Mais quand j'ai demandé à mes étudiants pourquoi ils aimaient tant ces BD,
j'ai commencé à comprendre le potentiel pédagogique des BD.
D'abord, contrairement à leurs livres de math,
ces BD enseignent de manière visuelle.
Nos étudiants ont grandi dans une culture visuelle.
Ils sont habitués à recevoir des informations sous cette forme.
Mais, contrairement à d'autres narrations visuelles,
comme les films, la télévision, les dessins animés ou les vidéos,
les BD sont ce que j'appelle « permanentes ».
Dans une BD, le passé, le présent et l'avenir sont réunis sur une page.
Donc, le débit du flux d'informations
est directement entre les mains du lecteur.
Quand mes étudiants ne comprenaient pas un point dans mes BD pédagogiques,
ils pouvaient simplement relire le passage à leur propre rythme.
C'était comme leur offrir une télécommande pour gérer l'information.
Ce n'était pas le cas avec les vidéos.
Et ce n'était pas non plus le cas avec mes cours en personne.
Quand je parle, je transmets l'information à la vitesse que je veux.
Donc, pour certains étudiants et certains types d'information,
les deux caractéristiques du média BD, sa nature visuelle et sa permanence,
en font un outil pédagogique incroyablement puissant.
Quand j'enseignais l'algèbre dans cette classe,
je travaillais aussi sur mon Master en pédagogie à Cal State East Bay.
Et j'étais si intrigué par cette expérience de BD pédagogiques
que j'ai décidé de dédier ma thèse finale à ce sujet.
Je voulais comprendre pourquoi les pédagogues américains
étaient historiquement si peu disposés à utiliser des BD dans leurs cours.
Voici mes découvertes.
Les BD sont devenues un média de masse dans les années 1940,
avec des millions de copies vendues chaque mois,
et les pédagogues de l'époque l'ont remarqué.
De nombreux professeurs innovateurs ont commencé
à apporté des BD dans leur cours à titre expérimental.
En 1944, le « Journal de sociologie éducative »
a consacré une édition entière à ce sujet.
Les choses semblaient progresser favorablement.
Les enseignants commençaient à se faire une idée.
Mais, ce type a débarqué,
un psychologue de l'enfant, Fredric Wertham.
En 1954, il a écrit un livre intitulé : « La séduction de l'innocent »,
dans lequel il soutient que les BD provoquent la délinquance juvénile.
(Rires)
Il avait tort.
En fait, Dr Wertham était un type plutôt honnête.
Il a consacré une partie de sa carrière à la délinquance juvénile.
et il a remarqué que la majorité de ses patients lisaient des BD.
Mais Wertham n'a pas réalisé que dans les années 1940 et 1950,
presque tous les gamins en Amérique lisaient des BD.
L'argumentation du Dr Wertham était plutôt douteuse,
mais son livre a incité le Sénat américain à tenir une série d'audiences
destinées à vérifier si les BD provoquaient la délinquance juvénile.
Ces audiences ont duré presque deux mois et n'ont débouché sur aucune décision,
mais elles ont considérablement endommagé la réputation des BD
aux yeux du public américain.
Suite à ça, tout éducateur américain respectable a fait marche arrière
et a gardé ses distances pendant des décennies.
Il a fallu attendre les années 1970,
pour que quelques âmes courageuses les réintègrent.
Et ce n'est que très récemment, une décennie environ,
que la BD a été acceptée par une audience plus large
parmi les enseignants américains.
Les BD et les romans illustrés sont, maintenant,
en train retourner dans les salles de classe américaines.
Cela arrive même à Bishop O'Dowd, là où j'enseignais.
M. Smith, ancien collègue, utilise « Comprendre la BD » de Scott McCloud
dans ses cours de littérature et cinéma car ce livre offre à ses étudiants
un langage avec lequel discuter de la relation entre mots et images.
M. Barnes demande à ses étudiants un essai en bandes dessinées chaque année,
la réalisation d'un roman en prose avec des images,
M. Barnes leur demande de réfléchir intensément non seulement à l'histoire
mais aussi à la manière dont elle est narrée.
Mme Murdock utilise mon travail, « Américain de souche chinoise »
avec ses étudiants en Anglais 1.
Selon elle, les romans illustrés sont un média formidable
pour satisfaire à une norme commune.
La norme stipule que les étudiants doivent pouvoir analyser
comment les éléments visuels participent au sens, au ton et à la beauté d'un texte.
Dans la bibliothèque, Mme Counts a rassemblé
une impressionnante collection d'histoires illustrées.
Avec ses autres collègues bibliothécaires,
Mme Counts a été une pionnière dans le plaidoyer en faveur de la BD
depuis le début des années 1980, quand un article d'un journal scolaire
a indiqué que la simple présence de bande dessinées dans la bibliothèque
augmentait de 80% l'utilisation de la bibliothèque,
et augmentait la circulation des autres livres de 30%.
Inspirée par ce renouveau dans l'intérêt des enseignants américains,
les dessinateurs américains produisent aujourd'hui plus de contenus éducatifs
pour la marché de l'éducation primaire que jamais auparavant.
Une majorité est destinée aux arts du langage,
mais de plus en plus de BD et d'histoires illustrées
commencent à s'attaque aux mathématiques et à la science.
Les BD relatives à la STEM sont vraiment
un territoire inexploré qui n'attend qu'à'être découvert.
L'Amérique prend enfin conscience
que les bandes dessinées ne provoquent pas la délinquance juvénile,
(Rires)
mais font partie des outils de tout éducateur.
Il n'y a aucune raison d'écarter la BD et les romans graphiques
du programme éducatif du primaire.
Ils enseignent visuellement.
Ils donnent à nos étudiants cette télécommande.
Leur grand potentiel éducatif est là,
qui n'attend qu'à être exploité par des créatifs comme vous.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)